what's up guys and welcome to Haris
hobbies where we discuss the hottest
tech news and open to the newest tech
products today we're taking a look at
why GPU prices are suddenly dropping and
if you should take this opportunity to
buy a new GPU or maybe wait a little bit
longer but before we begin make sure to
hit that subscribe button if you want to
stay updated with the latest tech news
live 2pcs and gaming so guys as it is
evident GPUs across the board have
experienced a dramatic price drop or are
consistently dropping at the very least
I'm not complaining but why exactly is
this happening now instead of any other
time well this nice drop is mainly due
to did less demand from minors for
gaming oriented GPUs and more supply
from Nvidia just last month Nvidia
announced they're working really hard to
crank up production in order to satisfy
gamers and the high cryptocurrency
mining demand and I think we are finally
starting to see the effects of the
increased supply provided by in video
while increased supply is great and all
I think the main culprit contributing
TVs major price drops is actually miners
if you guys didn't already know everyday
mining cryptocurrency gets more and more
difficult this difficulty increases no
matter what cryptocurrency you're mining
whether it's a Tyrian or a good-old
bitcoin why you ask well it's just like
money any resource in real life there's
only a limited amount of that resource
and as more and more people extract that
resource there's less and less of it and
toss it is harder to extract or in this
case mine and with the influx of miners
the difficulty is rising very quickly
for example if you're a Malone has
doubled in difficulty in just the last
three ones and this same trend can be
seen for other cryptocurrencies as well
while this may not mean anything for
seasoned miners and they may be cranking
it out just like usual this is
definitely a put-down for many new
people trying to get into mining
furthermore the price of various crypto
currencies has also been constantly
dropping in the last couple of months
going back to my example of aetherium we
can see that its price is almost
dropping half
in just in the last 30 days now this is
a big turn-off for all miners no matter
how much experience or knowledge you
have it's simply not easy to invest more
money into something that's constantly
dropping it is really unprintable as
well on top of this the introduction of
new AC computers that are specialized
computers built for task of mining
specific cryptocurrencies has only drawn
even more attraction from GPUs as a
result the volume of miners Biograph his
cars has seen a significant drop in the
last few months and this leads to more
supply and lust man and thus lower
prices so that is why graphics card
prices have been going down but should
you buy one well in my opinion no if it
was just a dropping of cryptocurrency
prices and I would be a bit iffy and and
I would have trouble telling guys
whether you should wait or go for it but
the introduction of new ASIC computers
that are really good in mining
performance have really got me convinced
that miners won't be interested in
graphics cards anymore and so I think
GPUs will drop much more and get really
close to MSRP and the only thing that
would be preventing them from reaching
MSRP would be overpriced RAM as a result
I think that you guys suggest wait and
save a good amount of money or even buy
a better graphics card due to the price
drop coming even if - worth taking out
of the picture I would have told you
that if you really want a GPU think you
should just spend the extra money but
here there is something special coming
soon in Vegas next line of gaming GPUs
is coming out very soon and at the very
latest it'll come out by the end of
summer so it's really just around the
corner so buying an overpriced NC or a
GPU doesn't really make much sense to me
so here's what I believe I think that
all of you guys should consider wait
until this holiday season to buy a
graphics card because by then RAM prices
should have returned to normal and
miners should be totally out of the
picture
unless something radical happens in this
short
time which I doubt and you'll have more
buying option when buying a jeep you as
well by then you'll have a twenty series
the ten series to six years I'm Andy and
possibly even Nabi to choose from and
they will all be a MSRP which is even
better plus by then optimization and
performance would have stabilized
thus you guys can make a much more
educated decision as well finally there
will also be Black Friday and Cyber
Monday deals if you live in the United
States and Christmas deals as well
worldwide so then you guys had saved a
lot more money and even buy a better GPU
so overall the difficulty of mining has
been constantly going up and the price
of air cryptocurrencies is constantly
going down and there are better mining
options and so a lot of demand has been
taken off gaming GPUs and thus gaming
GPUs are dropping in price however you
guys should wait to buy a graphics card
until the holiday season in order to be
able to save some money get more options
and be more educated about your possible
options well there you have it guys
that is why GPU price have been dropping
and why you guys should consider waiting
a little bit more buy these GPUs plus
you have already been waiting for a long
time so you might as well make it worth
it but that's pretty much all I have for
you guys this time if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure to drop a like and
post your thoughts down below and of
course subscribe but until next time bye
[Music]